but i don't think that's it's fair to uh
connect you to say you know like a
neo-nazi group you're clearly not white
supremacists no
that being said some of your members
were in charlottesville i was in
charlottesville
so so so what was that all about were
you the very fine people that trump was
talking about i think i was a very fine
people that trump was talking about
actually
um i actually went there on their media
capacity um
to record um i also felt some type of
way about tearing down statues period
whether you their work of art you know
they're supposed to make you feel some
sort of way and i felt like there was
there was protesters on both sides there
was protesters on the other side
that uh felt like they needed to take
the statute down
but that didn't mean that there weren't
people on both sides
that weren't utter garbage and usually
the people on both sides
uh that were utter garbage were the ones
sitting in the back and they waited
they waited till like the end of the the
event to
start these clashes um i saw it from my
own eyes heather hair lost her life
right but i saw an antifa black block
with a broken flagpole trying to harpoon
somebody
and the only reason that they weren't
successful is because that guy was
wearing a plate carrier
or else it would have been two deaths i
mean i'm talking about this guy what was
ramming this thing full speed at him
and uh luckily it was broken up and
state police was
like maybe 10 feet away and he just
turned his back
to this so that you know that
let police do their job sometimes just
doesn't work sometimes you have to step
in and i'm not saying
to be a vigilante i'm not telling
anybody to be a vigilante and i don't
think you should be a vigilante but
sometimes we could
we can do something and we can be
smarter
but yes there was people on both sides
the that
were horrible but there was people on
both sides that i saw conversations
where people were having hey i think
that we should tear down the statue
uh it's a statue to slavery and somebody
else was saying no this isn't a statue
of slavery and they had like their
compelling arguments
and we don't have enough of that you
know and the media that doesn't sell
yeah that doesn't get clicks and these
media giants are corporations
their their main purpose is to make
money and that's why they said do not
interview the proud boys even though
they got named
in a presidential debate one of the most
consequential in our lifetimes
i think it's extremely important to
figure out who you are what you stand
for
you know and what you're doing in terms
of charlottesville i believe
uh gavin issued a statement denouncing
the alt-right
yes but you one of wasn't one of the
organizers a proud boy
he came so so first we have to see what
a proud boy is
right in order to to say well he's a
member or not so a member is somebody
that's integrated into a chapter
because like let's say we're hanging out
at a bar you've heard of the proud boys
and you want to be part of the proud
boys but
you're in town let's say we're in miami
and you're from new york
so i could give you like a first degree
but that doesn't mean that you're a
member
like you have to integrate into a chat
what is a first degree first degree is
that you claim that you're a western
chauvinist and you refuse to apologize
for creating the modern world
that doesn't mean that you're a proud
boy that means like you're you're just
taking that
that pledge what's a chauvinist in this
context
well it's funny because we we use words
in certain ways
in order to get uh i guess to be
provocative
like american supremacist i guess it was
provocative when i was flying over here
but um chauvinist means uh
excessively patriotic is what it means
what that word means and people get that
confused
all the time with male chauvinists which
are two completely different things
like a person that's a male chauvinist
is extremely proud
to have a penis right or extremely proud
to be a man
um a western chauvinist is somebody
that's
excessively patriotic towards the west
western values
and in the case of american proud voices
we have proud voice chapters around the
world
including in eastern countries um
we're patriotic we're extremely
patriotic towards
america is that what you mean by west
specifically
yes well american proud boys yes but
western civilization also as a whole
created this awesome system where we're
able to sit
next to each other and broadcast to
millions of viewers
and in the comfort of of a studio what
then what's what's the what's the
opposite about what's the alternative to
western civilization eastern
civilization
well the opposite would be uh yeah it
would be eastern civilization
and it doesn't mean here's another thing
like just because
it's kind of like an america first thing
and then the first thing people think of
is like oh well you're crapping all over
the other countries no
it doesn't mean that we're putting other
countries last it means that we want to
put america first whether it's through
activism legislation anything that we do
in our lives we do want to put our
country first
now we have allies like mexico and
canada it doesn't mean that they're lost
we actually we're the most
giving country in the world we could
fund the u.n by ourselves we don't need
no help
but why would we do that so what have
they given us
so go i don't want to deviate too far i
do want to come back to the degrees of
proud boy but i want to take it back to
charlottesville uh real quick
so who was this guy and who was
organizing it
you're saying that he what he was he not
a proud boy or what
he he came to a meeting and uh
after that he didn't get integrated into
a chapter and then shortly after that
he decided to do uh the unite the right
rally which is
what it was called in charlottesville
and um we saw it coming from a mile away
that it was a horrible idea
it was just a stupid idea weren't there
like a vowed white nationalists
like before the event happened saying
they were organizing this they were
coming down
yeah there was there was people that
were saying that they're gonna come down
and and they're not gonna tear down
these statues but these were
these were the avowed white nationalists
so like you knew beforehand
who was gonna be there we knew yeah
obviously you knew it because after he
after he announced that this like even
the flyer was was cringy
you know that's why we knew it was it
wasn't gonna be a good event to go to
period so that's why gavin uh said
uh that he disavowed the entire event
and these guys were so stupid that they
thought that the first one went so good
that they started
making uh unite the right too which was
a good oh that was ridiculous
but uh but so so let me ask you uh
knowing who was organizing who was gonna
be there
and then even the night before you had
these people marching around as joe
biden likes to
you know constantly talk about the
people with the torches at a certain
point
don't you say like i don't want to be
here with these people
are you asking me personally yeah yeah i
mean you were there right yeah i was
there well i wasn't at that tiki torch
no no right right i wasn't at that i'm
just a torch and i wasn't there like as
an
activist i was there to record oh okay i
was there to record i didn't really i
did feel like i just said i did feel
some type of way of tearing down
history my parents
uh my grandfather's cuban and i've gone
to cuba many times
throughout my adult life and i've
understood
like what the consequences of a
socialist government is
i've understood them erasing history and
as a matter of fact
when che guevara and castro were taking
over the island
from the west coast to the east coast
there was this little farm
just outside the outskirts of a city
that needed that was
strategically important for the
revolution so they took over that farm
but they asked the family that was there
you know that they wanted to use the
farm as a forward operating base in
order to attack the city
well when that family declined they got
the two
oldest males and they brought them out
they put them on their knees they tagged
their hands behind their back
and they shot them in the back of their
head and that family shares last name
with me because they were my family
uh with the tarios so
i do know and and what they did on the
island after that
made my grandfather leave they started
erasing history
and the same thing the same thing that i
saw
uh what they wanted to do in
charlottesville again i wasn't gonna go
if if i didn't get a gig recording i
wouldn't have gone
i would have seen the mayhem from the
comfort of my phone
but uh it was it was something that
you needed to be there the media spun it
uh
in a way that i've never seen them spin
something like that before like before i
got to my hotel room that's it
it was it was chaos and there was chaos
uh but they focused on
small fringe groups they didn't focus on
people
they didn't focus on those small
conversations i had actually that was
the first time i met
daryl lamont jenkins and he was having
actually a really good conversation with
somebody
who who is who's daryl daryl lamont
jenkins a
self-identified member of antifa that
lives in the philadelphia area i believe
and i've had multiple conversations with
them before
out in dc portland i've seen them all
over the place but
he did have a conversation he did have
nasty conversations with people
but the media focuses
on the bad that's going on in the world
and people like to focus on
oh my god the civil war is coming i
don't believe that i believe like
you go to the grocery store talk to your
neighbor
the country isn't as divided as as the
magic light box
makes you think it is so
but it doesn't mean that we could just
sit idly and not do anything
and i don't i don't want to do that
thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you